Juston on the lit side when you were
working for innovative what were some of
the rules that you learned that were
maybe unspoken but that when something
came across your desk that you knew that
a writer was in a particular situation
or just some of the protocol that maybe
the rest of the world doesn't know about
until you're really in that industry
well as an assistant you take on a lot
of tasks and duties it's a very
difficult job and especially in my
situation at innovative working for
Nancy as I said she was representing
some of the best clients in town and so
she was very challenging she expected a
lot out of me
so it was mentally and physically
challenging on a daily basis but I
learned so much from her in that period
of time being there so the little things
that you learn are you know Nancy had a
stack of 100 scripts probably you know
on her desk overflowing on to the floor
and out the office door and 90 of those
would end up on my desk you know because
she only has the time to read the ones
that are potentially worth reading so my
job as someone who is reading these
scripts and doing coverage and
recommending clients or recommending
projects or giving notes was to get
through this stack of 90 or 100 or
whatever it was and get her the projects
that were worthwhile so to make my job
easier
you know because 90% of it at the office
was taking calls and scheduling meetings
and and meeting with our writers and our
directors and discussing their projects
you know these scripts were take-home
scripts so if I wanted to take my work
home with me and have nothing outside of
working at the agency and doing coverage
then you know I would look for an excuse
potentially not to read if I didn't have
to so there's the old cliche that you've
probably heard that you know when you're
starting to read a script if it you can
tell it's not a great story you'll read
the first 30 pages
then you'll read the last ten pages
because if the story doesn't unfold to
you or grab you or really get you going
within even the first 10 20 30 pages
then it's probably not even worth
reading the entire thing and then you
read the last 10 to see if anything
actually happened it blows your mind at
the end so but to get back to your
question I think the thing is what a lot
of people don't know is I would receive
scripts that would literally have money
attached and say here's $5 I'd love to
have you read my script and I would know
that although that's great and I'm sure
I took the $5 and spend it on something
nice I knew that that wasn't coming
probably from a legitimate writer so I
would look at the cover page I would
look at the concept see if it was
something that we were looking for but
most likely that type of project would
go from my desk into the trash because
there's 89 other scripts that I have to
read so it's the same thing with you
know scripts that would come with a
cover sheet that would have their name
their contact information five phone
numbers to get a hold of them at the WGA
registration number the copyright number
all these things a legitimate writer
who's been around this not Green is not
going to put all those things on the
cover page they're gonna put the title
they're gonna put their name and then
they're gonna maybe put one contact so
those types of things were telltale
signs I mean you just know who you're
dealing with at that point and I'm not
saying it's right I I would I love
reading
I would love to read everything that I
could there just isn't time for it and
unfortunately you know being it
innovative I read all those scripts and
I think you know we passed on probably
99% of them I think I recommended to
clients and the time that I was there
that we represented and I recommended
maybe a half a dozen projects and we
probably you know shopped a small number
of those so out of 500,000 scripts you
know that's a very small number it's
it's a cutthroat industry but I'm just
learning those things so for me as a
writer and developing my craft I knew a
little bit more of what I had to do to
get my script into the right hands what
I had to do to make sure that they
that I wasn't potentially green and then
I'd been around and I knew the business
and and everything that I did to try to
hopefully help me get my script in the
right hands and hopefully get it
financed or optioned or mate
you